我跟我男朋友谈了两年了，
感情都还挺稳定的，
然后他是90年的，
我是97年的，
我们都在国外工作，
然后一个月大概是月入1.8到两个，
就是我们两个都差不多是这个水平，
然后我是毕业已经工作了四年了，
都在国外，
我的原生家庭很穷，
一共是四兄妹三个哥哥，
然后我是最小的嘛，
就是因为原生家庭太穷了，
就是所以前两年的时候都在还各种助学贷款啊，
家里借的钱，
上学的钱什么的，
今年才把家里那个欠款还完，
然后现在谈了，
就跟男朋友的话，
感情就挺好的嘛，
然后她在他家里是在甘肃市区，
然后爸妈是工薪阶层，
已经退休了，
有退休金，
我是家里是农村的，
家里没有那个，
在市里没有房产什么的，
对，
因为已经谈了2年了，
本来因为原生家庭的问题，
我对婚姻是没有那个向往了，
跟他谈了这么久的话，
慢慢的改变了一些想法，
就可能还是向往那种稳定的家庭条件，
可能慢慢就要涉及到那种见父母的温泉嘛，
但是我觉得给我爸妈在农村的话，
哎，
他们的那个卫生习惯太差了，
就是每次回家感觉那个到处都是垃圾啊，
灶台。
啊什么的都非常脏乱差，
但是我男朋友家里他那种是非常干净卫生的嘛，
我就想如果要是以后带他回家的话，
我怕他会嫌弃啊什么的，
哎，
我不知道怎么去，
我跟你讲一些个问题，
我跟你讲姐妹这个事儿啊，
确实是存在很大的问题，
如果说你男朋友他本身从小生活的环境，
假设他一直都是用抽水马桶的，
假设他找了一个女朋友，
这女朋友家里面是用旱厕的，
他们这这很难适应的，
所以没必要，
为什么一定要带回家呢？
为什么一定要有家三和礼呢？
我可以不办呢？
我读了书，
我有了学识，
我我现在在国外工作，
我要用我自己想要的方式来结婚，
我为什么一定要办婚礼，
我可以旅行结婚，
我甚至可以对吧，
搞一个什么项目，
公益结婚都可以，
就是你现在要有什么思维的姐妹主人思维我说了算，
就是我的婚姻，
我的婚礼我想要的我说了算，
你不要老想着你爸爸妈妈会不会觉得，
哎，
女儿都已经嫁人了，
没有在家里面摆个酒席，
觉得丢脸啊什么的，
丢的是他们的脸，
对吧？
其实这个白薯的话我倒是啊，
倒是没有很想说要办婚礼一定要办婚礼，
但是就是总想着那也不可能不见面吧，
总是要见一面什么的可以啊，
这种问题是。
嗯，
可能双方父母见面就不是很方便了，
因为距离太远，
然后我爸他的话，
他年纪也大了嘛，
然后他是农村呢，
出行也很不方便，
你完全可以约在那个酒店见面，
约一个餐厅见面，
不一定非得说南方父母一定要去你们家住一晚吗？
不需要，
完全可以约在那个，
比如说甘肃的那个敦煌，
敦煌的那个什么飞天那个什么旅游景点，
正好南方父母也来旅游景点来旅趟游，
你父母也出趟门，
约到那儿见一面完事儿啊，
视频通话也行，
开个视频会议也行，
不是前面你一定要有这种跳脱出别人的结婚模式的这样一个想法，
不是所有的人的结婚模式都得要一个模式，
你现在已经是咱说句那个什么变话，
高级知识分对不对，
既然你是高级知识分子，
你要有知识分子的那份自信。
我想要的结婚模式是什么样子的？
我明确告诉你，
我现在的结婚模式就跟趴地酱是一样的。
她毕竟就是她跟她老公结婚的时候，
她是双方父母不认识，
我也是我们双方父母到现在都没有手机号不认识，
你理解这个逻辑了吗？
我为什么一定要遵循别人的结婚模式，
除说双方父母要坐下来要谈啊什么的，
我自己不能谈吗？
我是在想我男朋友去我们那边见面的话，
因为我们家是很农村的地方，
就是比如说我，
我回到广西之后，
我还要坐大巴回到县里，
从市里坐小车那种私家车回到镇上，
再从镇上再安排车坐到村里那种环境，
那如果说他折腾这么大一圈到我们那边，
你不去家里见面，
还安排在镇上见面，
就感觉挺奇怪的，
你都到了那里了，
你也不再回答一下，
我真的挺嫌弃我的原生家庭的，
但是我可能说我自己嫌弃他们，
但是我会接受他们，
我现在的问题就是说我不一定能保证我男朋友他也能接受这样的一个环境，
我就是挺无奈的，
因为我知道我改变不了他们，
所以我作为男女是愿意接纳他们，
就是说我不知道作为一个外人怎么去处理这个问题，
我觉得首先第1点在心里，
不要强求别人能够接纳你的父母，
不要强求别人能够接纳你的生活环境，
这是第一点，
第2点也不要强求别人非得到你那儿去看。
就不看就不能结了吗？
这婚他去你父母那看一眼，
这事他是法律规定的吗？
必须要有这个环节吗？
不看的话就结不成婚了吗？
但是还是说想带他们让跟你见一见你的男朋友见一见你怎么不该见？
为什么不可以约在外面见到？
因为他们身行动非常不便，
像我妈的话，
她是我也可以已经在后一阵保持诚信啊。
他也不会说普通话。
我这小姑娘，
你一定要跳脱出来，
不要被困在那样的程序里面，
我们自己编一个程序不可以吗？
嗯，
因为我以后肯定是不会再回我们家那边生活的，
我就是说在意这个怎么去。
联系一下，
就是可能就是像你说的，
可能在视频上见一见就好了，
对呀，
也可以呀，
其实父母就是希望你快乐，
希望你幸福，
对不对，
这个不一定的，
他们还想着不要找那么远的，
就找一个近一点的嫁的就算了，
我是虽然有三个哥哥，
但是我们这个家庭真的是被父母影响非常深，
因为小时候家里很穷，
我爸又非常懒，
他们我因为像其他家里的父母一样说啊，
出去打工挣点钱，
然后他们就是在家务农，
根本就没有钱，
第一你有知识对吧，
第二你有能力，
你能够在印尼能赚到钱工作，
你的知识和能力都是到位的，
第三你现在需要干的是什么事情啊，
需要的是把自己从原来那种旧思想的一个鞋子里面爬出来，
把那个鞋子扔掉，
把那个盒子扔掉，
你现在是被一个旧的思想装在了一个盒子里，
你现在需要的是爬出来把那个盒子扔掉，
所有那个旧的那些风婚俗风俗你都把他扔掉，
就是说我和我的现在的这个男朋友，
只要我们两个人两情相悦，
只要我们两个人性格合适，
只要我们两个人在一起工作生活很快乐，
我们不一定非得办婚礼不一。
并非得见双方的家长，
不一定非得到双方的家里面去走那个程序，
为什么这样，
在外军令有所不受，
你本来就不在国内，
你都在国外了是不是？
嗯，
确实是这个要反正我只是想听一听意见而已，
因为家里他是没有办法给我提供任何的帮助了，
我只是说在连接这一方面，
我不太懂得要怎么去处理，
所以就想听一听，
OK,
这个意我给你个意见，
就是你现在已经有能力从这个盒子里面走出来了，
只是你自己还不知道，
你已经有这个能力了，
那今天龙飞姐就告诉你，
你一定可以的，
只要你从这个盒子里面走出来，
你就自由了，
你从此以后你就是一个主体思维，
凡事我想怎么干我就怎么干，
只要我干这件事情，
对吧？
没违法，
没犯罪，
没有伤害到谁的利益，
我就这么干，
做一个强势的女人很幸福的，
就是说在思想上做一个强势的女人很幸福的，
咱不一定说在语言上啊，
在动作上就得做一个强势的女人，
但是在自己的思想上一定要做一个特强势的女人，
特有主意的女人，
好吧，
嗯，
还有我就是想问一下关于这个彩礼的事情，
就是我我不知道就是不是每个家庭都必须要有这种。
彩礼的时候法，
我建议你还是要吧，
自己看着就是我内心就觉得多多少少的，
我要要一点，
一直要到自己手里嘛，
8万也好，
6万也好，
10万也好，
看喽，
跟对方的当地的习俗了，
嗯，
好的，
嗯嗯，
谢谢我凯老师，
嗯，
其实我特别能理解这个姑娘，
因为嗯，
我自己的那个就是爸爸妈妈的那个家，
我给你们描述一下好不好，
我们家的那个厕所是和猪圈在一起的，
是挖了，
下面挖了一个坑，
上面搭了一个台子，
台子上面养的是猪，
然后人上厕所的时候，
在这架两个板子，
在这两个板子那儿蹲着，
人上厕所和猪拉的屎都在那个坑里，
这是我们家的那个状态，
农村的那个灶，
这边这个灶是给猪吃的，
这边这个灶是给人做的，
有的时候给人做的啊，
就是洗了那些锅里的油啊什么的，
就把那个水就舀到那个猪的那个锅里面去，
然后这边就给猪煮煮猪吃的那些什么菜叶子呀，
玉米面子呀，
猪那些，
所以我特别能够理解这个姑娘，
我就明确告诉你们好吧，
我老公到目前为止没有去过我家，
我不想带他去，
但也没有去过我老公老家，
我也不想去，
我只想告诉。
大家每个人啊，
就一定要有自己的主宰自己的这样一个思维，
不是说结婚这个男的就一定非得到你家去，
你就一定非得到咱家去吗？
不一定，
一定要学会主宰自己的婚姻节奏，
主宰自己的婚姻模式，
主宰自己的生活，
要过好自己的日子。
我讲这个就像给刚才那个姐妹给你一点力量，
我能理解你，
你不要困在那样的状态下，
说我一一定要怎么样，
一定要怎么样呢？
No,
就是你自己一定要学会主宰自己的婚姻啊，
主宰自己的生活状态，
主宰他。
碰到有的人说姐夫好可怜哦，
他好幸福呀，
己所不欲，
勿施于人，
我但凡能想到会给他带来麻烦，
会给带来心里不舒服的事儿，
我都不会逼他干，
我再给你们聊一聊好不好，
今天就给你们聊透了，
我家要是来什么亲戚啊，
来什么朋友啊，
我都不会强行的要求他赔的。
我直接给他找个借口，
香港呢，
出差了，
嗯，
在香港呢，
公司有事，
嗯，
工作很忙，
他要加班，
我们家来什么亲戚，
就我自己陪就可以了。
同样的道理，
他对我给予了相应的叫什么理解，
他们家要来什么亲戚，
来什么朋友，
只要我不想参与的，
他也不会强迫我，
两口子得琢磨一套相互能适应对方的这样一个生活哲学吧，
我不会强迫他，
我不会让他有一点点不舒服，
他只要我能感受到他不愿意干这个事情的话，
我自己干。
我自己去，
我自己接待，
他也不会强迫我，
他只要感觉到我不愿意吃这顿饭，
我不愿意吃这个人我不愿意见，
他也不会让我去见啊，
我只是给大家提供一个就提供一个思路吧，
并不是说龙村就是鼓励大家，
鼓励大家都这么干啊，
就是看你们两口子能不能接受。